okay I'd like to compare and contrast
passive with active transport so passive
transport is how molecules move from a
high to low concentration but active
transport is really just the opposite
how molecules move from below to a high
concentration you'll often hear in
passive transport molecules move down
their concentration gradient and an
active transport molecules move up or
against their concentration gradient
passive transport requires no cellular
cellular energy no ATP but during active
transport cells must spend ATP the
energy of the cell in order to perform
active transport so the reason for the
river and the kayakers the Chi Erika
kayaker in black is symbolic of passive
transport because the kayaker and black
can just sit back spend no energy and
let the current take the kayaker
downstream but the colored kayaker
because he's facing the opposite
direction that the river is flowing has
to paddle very rigorously in order to
move uphill that's our upstream that's
an example of moving up the
concentration gradient that was an
example of active transport some
examples of each diffusion osmosis
facilitated diffusion these are examples
of passive transport and in active
transport the sodium potassium pump
contractile vacuoles endocytosis and
exocytosis we are going to talk about
each as we go through this so let's go
ahead and start with passive transport
the movement of molecules from a high to
a low concentration as I said a moment
ago passive transport does not require
the use of ATP energy great example of
passive transport is diffusion and a
great example of diffusion is how
molecules like oxygen can enter the
bloodstream you know in our lungs we
have thousands and thousands of these
air sacs called alveoli and every time
we inhale the air sacs fill up with o2
they fill up with oxygen when that
happens I hope
you can see there's a high concentration
of oxygen in the alveoli and there's a
low concentration of oxygen in the
bloodstream so oh - is such a small
molecule that can actually pass through
the layer of the alveoli into the
bloodstream when it's then picked up by
a red blood cell from high to low
concentration another oxygen molecule
will slip through the alveoli into the
blood and one more time oxygen slips
through picked up by a red blood cell
and carried throughout the body so this
is diffusion where molecules are really
moving from a high to low concentration
and they're small enough where they can
just pass through the outer layers
another example of passive transport is
something called as Moses and this is
really the same thing as diffusion only
it's the diffusion of water so here's a
cell that's been placed in distilled
water distilled water is highly
concentrated it's pure h2o there's no
other impurities in it and so if you
were to place a cell in distilled water
I want to note the high concentration of
waters on the outside of the cell but
inside the cell there's a lower
concentration so through osmosis through
passive transport water molecules will
diffuse into the cell and the cell will
expand possibly to the point where can
even burst so this is a great example of
osmosis which is again an example of
passive transport and the last example
of passive transport that I want to
mention is something called facilitated
diffusion and this is a great example of
how glucose is removed from our blood
first of all the word facilitate means
simply to help glucose is a fairly large
molecule and it needs help getting past
the cell membrane into the cells so
there's these little protein channels
these little gateways that will allow
molecules like glucose to come into the
cell so after we have a meal the amount
of glucose
increases in our blood and ultimately
this can be hazardous if too much
glucose builds up and builds up and
builds up so what happens is that the
pancreas will release insulin to cause
these channels or these doorways here to
open and once that happens you can see
there's a high concentration of glucose
in the blood there's a low concentration
of glucose in the cells so from high to
low concentration the glucose simply
diffuses into the cells tell your cells
get the food that they need in order to
do their cellular functions but a great
example of passive transport no ATP
energy was required and the molecules
move from a the glucose molecules move
from a high to a low concentration so
let's go ahead and switch focus now to
active transport and as I said earlier
it's the movement of molecules from a
low concentration to a high it really is
the opposite of passive transport you
know you're often going to see active
transport compared to pumps and so
here's two bicycle pumps whether it's
the foot pedal pump on the right or the
handlebar pump on the left in order to
operate a pump you have to lift up and
down on the handles or step up and down
on the pedal and you have to spend
energy pumps require the use of energy
and then in the world of cells energy
comes from a molecule called adenosine
triphosphate ATP so active transport
requires the use of ATP energy in order
to move molecules from a low to a high
concentration so a great example of a
cellular pump would be the sodium
potassium pump the sodium potassium pump
is really important in the role of how a
neuron or a nerve cell sends an
electrical signal to another and it will
pump sodium out of the neuron and will
pump potassium into the neuron I want
you to pay attention to the brown
sodium's at the bottom notice how
there's a lower concentration of sodium
at the bottom and there's a greater
concentration of sodium at the top what
happens is three sodium's at a time
we'll load into the sodium-potassium
pump and along comes a molecule of ATP
now when ATP is broken heat gets
released the heat causes the sodium
potassium pump to change shapes and it
allows the sodium to be removed from the
neuron well it's not just called the
sodium pump that's called the sodium
potassium pump now I want you to focus
your attention on the purple k's the
purple potassium notice how there's a
lower concentration of potassium on top
and there's a greater concentration of
potassium on the bottom two potassium at
a time will load in the sodium potassium
pump and it will change back to its
original shape to draw the potassium
into the neuron great example of a pump
that's designed to pump molecules from a
low to high concentration with the use
of ATP another great example is what's
called the contractile vacuole that some
cells have here you might recognize this
is a cell called a paramecia this is a
freshwater creature called a Paramecium
it's in the kingdom Protista microscopic
you need a microscope to see it and
right there I've just highlighted the
contractile vacuole and what this thing
does is to prevent the cell from
bursting from taking on too much water
it will squeeze out extra amounts of
water it's a pump it's a water pump
let's look at this in a little more
detail so here's a just a drawing of the
Paramecium in its watery environment and
all these black dots represent water
molecules now right now you can see
there's a high concentration of water
outside the cell and there's a low
concentration of water inside so right
now it's through simple as Moses water
will diffuse into the Paramecium now
that's an example of passive transport
but watch what happens the Paramecium
will respond by using its contracting
vacuole
it's contractile vacuole and it will
pump the extra amounts of water from a
low concentration to a high
concentration it gets rid of the
incoming water so it doesn't burst and
this is how cells like Paramecium can
survive in a watery environment and then
finally I want to finish up with
endocytosis and exocytosis two examples
of active transport where the cells will
take molecules in or out with the use of
ATP you know here's a bacterial cell and
here comes a white blood cell and this
is going to be a great example of
endocytosis so the white blood cell will
slowly devour and wrap its cytoplasm
around the bacteria until the bacteria
has been taken into the cell that's what
endocytosis means endo means within
saito means the cell so the bacteria has
been taken into the cell now the the
white blood cell needs to spend some ATP
energy in order to do this and once the
bacteria is trapped efore enzymes are
placed inside of that little protective
pouch that the vat that the the bacteria
has been placed within and eventually
the bacteria will be killed it's one way
that the white blood cells protect us
from infection so to finish up this
video on active transport I want to
mention the process called exocytosis
which is really to get rid of or to
release materials from the cell so here
comes a cell part known as a vesicle the
vesicle perhaps is carrying those black
dots maybe those black dots are proteins
that the cell is going to get rid of and
what happens is the vesicle will
actually fuse with the cell membrane of
the plasma membrane because the vesicle
and the plasma membrane are made from
the same molecules a phospholipid
bilayer and ultimately those black dots
those proteins will then be released
outside the cell and again this process
requires the use of ATP in or
for this to happen great example again
of active transport okay so I just
wanted to return to this slide right
here where you could compare and
contrast passive versus active transport
you know I'd love to hear your thoughts
place them in the comment box below
let me know how useful this video was
good luck in your understanding of
biology